METE ATAMEL: All right.
So let's get started.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Mete Atamel.
First of all, thanks for
coming to my session.
And today we're going to talk
about Containers, Kubernetes,
and Google Cloud.
This is going to
be an intro level
session on why containers,
why Kubernetes,
and what does Kubernetes
really do for your containers
applications.
So before I start
my talk, there's
some information about myself.
This is my Twitter.
So I'm going to post the
slides after my talk.
So if you want the slides,
just follow me on Twitter.
And I also have my email.
If you have any questions about
any of this stuff I say today,
you can reach out
to me at any time.
And after my talk I'm going to
go and be at the experts area.
So if you have any questions,
I'll be there as well.
I also have a talk
feedback link,
git.ly slash my last name.
So if you have any
feedback about my talk,
please leave them there as well.
Also today, I'm originally from
Cyprus, and I live in London.
But today I was
walking to this event.
And I didn't know
if you guys know.
There is a website
called 23andMe.
Anyone knows what that is?
It's basically like a
genetic profiling site.
So you sign up and then
they send you a kit.
And you send your DNA,
it's basically your saliva.
And then they tell you
where you are from.
So as I was walking today, I
was waiting for that result
for two months now.
I got the results.
And it said that I'm 75% from
the areas around Cyprus, which
is not surprising.
But 25% I'm from Sardinia.
That's what I learned today.
So I guess I'm 25%
Italian in some ways.
So I think it was a great
place to learn that today.
So that was kind
of exciting for me.
Anyway, so let's think
about software development.
So when you think of
software development, what
does come to your mind first?
Anyone?
AUDIENCE: DevOps.
METE ATAMEL: DevOps.
OK, what else?
Software development, is it fun?
Yes, maybe, not so much.
Is it easy?
Maybe.
Well for me, when I think of
software development nowadays,
I think of this.
I think software
development is really hard.
The only people who really
told me that it's not hard
is usually the product managers.
They think that
everything is possible
and you should do-- you should
have done everything yesterday.
But if you talk to software
engineers, it's really hard.
And the thing is, it's
not getting any easier.
You would think that
with the passage of time,
with the tools and
cloud and everything,
things would get easier.
But that's not the case,
at least in my experience.
So anyone remembers these?
Yeah, some people?
OK.
It's always good to have a
few people who remember these,
so I'm not the oldest
guy in the room.
Basically back in the--
I didn't use the bigger ones.
But I used the small one,
the one in the middle.
Back in the day, you
would have your MS-DOS.
You would put in
your floppy drive.
You would close it.
You would turn your computer on.
It will load the operating
system in like a minute or two,
and then you would get the a
prompt, and then from then on,
you would take the
operating system out.
You put the Basic--
I think I used QBasic
or GWBasic when I first
started programming.
And then you would just get into
Basic and start coding, right?
And the thing is
there was no internet.
There was nothing.
So this was literally the only
thing I had to worry about.
When you think of
microservices, there's
this notion of bounded context.
Well, back then, the
context was this disk.
And it was like physical.
So you could see it.
You could feel it.
And life was really easy.
I remember all I
had was this disk.
And then I had a book on Basic.
And I would just look at
my book, do some stuff.
Look at my book, do some stuff.
I mean at some point it
was hard, because there
was no Stack Overflow.
So if you are stuck, there's
no one to ask help for.
But I like the simplicity
of those times.
Because all I had to worry
about was just I have a problem
and I want to
solve that problem.
Since then, a lot
of things changed.
The first thing is
obviously internet.
And then after the internet,
we had all these things
that happened.
So we had object-oriented
programming, virtual machines,
cloud computing, caching,
machine learning.
So it's really impossible to
stay on top of all of this.
So what I try to do as
a software engineer,
is I pick and
choose what I like,
and try to learn
as much as I can.
For example, microservices is
one thing that I really like.
So I try to learn
as much as I can.
And I'm trying to learn
about machine learning.
Because that's where
the programming is
going to evolve into.
But then I also try
to get an overview
of the rest of the
landscape, so I know what
the landscape is all about.
But it is impossible to learn
and know everything nowadays.
So nowadays if you have
a problem, what you do
is you start with
the code again.
So you write your code.
So let's assume that
this is the piece of code
that you wrote to
solve a problem.
It's not on the disk anymore.
Its usually hosted on
some kind of server.
So you find a server
somewhere, and host your code.
It can be your server
maybe, or maybe
its some Cloud provider server.
So it doesn't matter.
Your code runs on a
server somewhere, right?
And then someone
says, what happens
if that server goes down.
What do you do?
So you have to have redundancy.
So what you do is you basically
add a number of servers.
It depends on how many you
want, but usually 2-3 is enough.
And then you run the same
code on those machines.
But then the clients,
they need to know
the IPs of those machines.
That's not ideal.
So what you do is you
create a load balancer that
has a stable virtual
IP, and then the clients
will talk to the load balancer.
And it will get to the
machines, as it needs to.
So all of a sudden, you have
your code, your machines,
and your load balancer.
But then how do you know your
machines are actually healthy?
So to do that,
what you usually do
is you create what's
called a health endpoint.
And that will check what it
means for your application
to be healthy.
And then if it's
healthy, it will say, OK.
If it's not healthy,
it will say not OK.
But someone has to actually
check these health endpoints.
So what you have is
usually a health checker
that will ping these endpoints
and check whether that machine
is healthy or not.
And if it's not
healthy, you probably
want to create a new machine
and add your code there as well.
So this is great for one zone,
everything lives in one zone.
But you are relying
on a single zone.
And as we know, even in the
cloud, sometimes zones go down.
So what do you do?
You create the whole
setup in a different zone
with the same load balancers,
same machines, same health
check and everything.
So this is good.
So I have redundancy.
But then how do I
keep the two in sync?
So that's another problem.
So what you usually do is you
have something in the middle.
You either have a
master or a slave,
or you have some
kind of task here
in the middle, where
the state from one zone
gets replicated to
the other states.
So that way they are in sync.
So that's great.
I have two zones
that are replicated
and everything is good.
But what if my application
is getting really popular,
and I need to scale up?
Right You can scale up
manually as you need to.
But it's difficult. Because
usually applications,
they have cyclic graphs.
So people use them a
lot during the day.
But at night they
don't use them as much.
So you usually scale
up during the day,
and you scale down
during the night.
So no one wants to
do that manually.
So what you usually do is
you create auto scaler that
will look at your load
somehow, and figure out
how to scale up and down.
So this is how it
looks like nowadays.
And it gets much more
complicated than this.
But this is like
the basic scenario
that you implement usually.
And this is for
running a piece of code
on a single type of machine.
If you need to run different
types of applications
in different languages, on
different kinds of machines,
then you have more work to do.
If you want to deploy a new
version of your application,
then you need to worry
about this whole machines
and zones and stuff like that.
So it's not so easy to deploy
your new version anymore.
If there's something wrong
with that new version
and you need to roll back
to the previous version,
you need to do that in a
consistent and stable way.
If you want to do
configuration and secrets
of your application, you
need to manage them somehow.
You need to make sure that
they are centrally managed
and you need to somehow
get them working with all
the machines in a certain way.
And if you need to do
scripts, because usually
when the machines
come up, they usually
have some kind of
scripts to run.
So that's not the code.
But it's actually things that
make your application work.
So you need to manage
those scripts as well.
So there's all sorts
of things that you
need to worry about right now.
So if you're like me, you're
probably feeling like this guy
right now.
You just want to write some
code to solve some problem.
But now all of a
sudden you have to deal
with all these problems.
So the reality of today
is kind of like this.
You want to care about the
code that you're writing.
That's what you're trying to do.
But then in reality this is
all you are trying to do.
You're are trying to create
all this infrastructure
so that your code runs
in a consistent, stable,
and resilient way, basically.
And actually in one
place that I worked
before, this ratio of
coding versus operations
got so bad for me that I
was spending 90% of my time
trying to manage all of this,
rather than writing the code.
So this balance
has to be really,
really maintained properly.
So what do we do?
Well, in the good old
days up until recently,
what we used to do is that
first we write our code.
And then we pass that
code to QA for testing.
Because as software engineers,
we don't test our code.
That's someone else's job.
So we'll pass it to
QA and say, just go
ahead and test this code.
They will find some bugs.
Send them to us.
We will fight back and forth
whether they are bugs or not.
Eventually we will fix the bugs
and if the QA person is happy,
then we'll pass it
to operations people
and let them deal
with it in production.
Let them run it.
Because as software
engineers, we
don't have to worry about
running code in production.
We can just let someone
else worry about that.
So we took this hands-off
approach basically
where we just write
our code, and just
give it to people for testing,
and give it to people to run,
and it's not really our problem.
Well, this didn't really work,
so that's why we have DevOps.
So I'm sure most of you know
what DevOps is, but in DevOps,
basically the idea is
that you write your code,
you test your code,
you run your code.
And if there's something
broken, you fix it.
And you basically have the
full lifecycle of your code.
There are good things and
bad things about DevOps.
The good thing is that
you have that feedback
loop that you need as a
software engineer to write
really good code.
Because you have an
incentive not to wake up
in the middle of
the night, so you
make sure that your code is
resilient and actually works,
I've seen it work.
But then with DevOps,
you need it to make sure
that you have the
tools and the resources
and the structure that
you need to do it right.
So I've seen some places
where they just think
that they're doing DevOps.
But what they're
doing is actually
they're just deploying
code as fast as possible,
and let the code
burn in production.
And then with that, the whole
development team burns as well.
Because they're
spending so much time
trying to fix
things in production
rather than writing the code.
So what do we do then?
So if I have to imagine how
software development should be,
I think there are three
things that I want to be true.
The first thing is that I
want as a software engineer,
I want to write code
in any language I want.
And I want that code to
run exactly the same way
everywhere.
Because I don't want
to be constrained
by certain languages.
And when I run my
code on my laptop,
I want to make sure
that it exactly
runs the same way in
the cloud as well.
I want this to be true.
The second thing is
that I want my code
to be optimally deployed
somewhere and managed
by someone.
But I shouldn't really
worry about that myself,
because I'm solving problems.
I'm thinking about
business problems.
I don't necessarily need to
figure out every single time
where should I put this
code or is the server
the right place to put it.
Someone has to do that for me.
I mean you would think that
at this point in software
development, we will
get to the point
where this is done for us.
And the third thing
is that I don't even
want to think about machines.
I want to think about problems
and solving those problems
with code.
I want machines to be available
to me when I need them.
I want them to scale
up when they need to.
down as they need to.
If I need some
kind of data store,
I want that to be
available to me.
I shouldn't worry
about machines,
provisioning machines, and
all that kind of stuff.
So this is what I want.
And if you look at the last
few years in the industry,
we are actually moving
in this direction.
So when we think about writing
your code in any language
and running it anywhere,
that's basically
what containers are all about.
So Docker and Rocket,
they're basically
trying to create this context
for your applications,
where the context really
transfers from your laptop
to your cloud.
And your application
runs in that context
in a consistent way.
When we think about
your app being optimally
deployed and managed,
that's the whole point
of container
management platforms
like Kubernetes and
Mesos and Docker Swarm
and things like that.
So all they are trying to
do is run your containers
in a consistent way anywhere.
And the third thing
about all the resources
being available when
you need them, well,
that's what the
cloud is all about.
So Google Cloud and
other cloud providers,
they're all trying to make it
so that the resources that you
need is available
when you need them.
So we are going in
the right direction
and we have tools and
clouds to do the job.
So we'll take a look at
Kubernetes today, and see
how that provides what we need.
So now what I'm
going to do is, first
I want to build a really
simple Hello World service.
And I'm going to do
that in Google Cloud.
And then later we'll
take this service,
and we'll containerize
it using Docker,
and see how that looks like.
And once it's containerized,
we'll take the container image,
push it to Google Cloud so that
we can use it in other places,
and then we're going to
create a Kubernetes cluster.
And we'll use that container
in Kubernetes cluster.
So through that we'll learn
what Kubernetes is all about.
So first let's, look
at our microservice.
And for this I'm using an
ASP .NET Core application.
So are there any
.NET developers here?
No?
OK.
Well .NET used to run on
Windows and nowhere else.
But recently ASP .NET Core
came along and it is basically
a multiplatform version of .NET
that runs on Windows, Linux,
and Mac.
And I'm really impressed by the
fact that .NET runs on Linux.
So I'm using that in my demos.
So we'll use that application
as a starting point
for our microservice.
But you can use any kind
of application here.
The language doesn't
really matter.
So here I am Google
Cloud Console.
This is the main console
to manage our projects
in Google Cloud.
I activate Cloud Shell.
This gives you a development
environment in the cloud.
So by clicking there, I'm
basically getting a Linux box
somewhere in the cloud.
And I also have
a home page where
I can create my applications.
So I am in browser, and I
can access to my Linux box.
So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to first--
so if I just type dotnet, that's
the command line tool to create
.NET applications.
It's already installed
in Cloud Shell.
So I don't need to worry
about installing that.
What I'm going to do
is I'm going to create
a folder for my application.
I'm going to call it
Hello World ASP .NET Core.
And then once I
have that folder,
I'm going to use the dotnet
command line tool to create
a Hello World application.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say dotnet New-TWeb.
So this creates that web
Hello World application.
And if you look at
the files, there's
a lot of files they
have created for us.
Program.js is the main entry
point to my application.
So I'm going to edit that file.
And I'm going to add a single
line to the program of js,
to make sure that my
application binds to port 8080.
Because I want to be able
to test this application
from the browser.
So to do that, I want to make
sure it starts on port 8080.
So I'm adding one line that
says [INAUDIBLE] in HTTP *8080.
This way, my application,
when it starts up,
it starts on port 8080.
So I go back.
The first thing that I need
to do is dotnet restore.
So this basically it looks
at the project .JSON file.
This is the file that
determines the dependencies
on my application.
It will find the
dependencies, and it
will download them from NuGet.
NuGet is the dependency
management platform on .NET.
So we'll go to NuGet,
restore the dependencies
so that I have all
the dependencies here.
Once I have that I
can do dotnet run.
And this will run the
application on the Linux box.
And then we will preview and
makes sure that it works.
And once it works, we
can containerized it.
So I'm doing dotnet run.
So this will compile the
application on Linux,
and then it will
run it on port 8080.
So once we see the prompt that
it's running on port 8080,
we know that the
application is working.
And there's a nice feature
of Cloud Shell, Web Preview,
so if I click that, it will find
the Linux box that I'm running.
And it will bind to
port 8080 automatically.
So I don't have to worry about
the IPs and stuff like that.
So now my app is
running on Linux.
So nothing fancy, but we'll
use this as a reference app
to container SM1.
So we've got our app.
Next step is containers.
I mean why should we even
bother with containers?
So let's try to answer
that question first.
If you look at what we used
to do up until recently,
we used to do
something like this.
We would have a
physical machine.
We would install the kernel,
the operating system,
on the machine.
And then we will install
all the tools and libraries
that we need for
our applications.
And then we'll deploy our
applications on top of that.
The good thing about
this is that there
was a single machine,
single operating system,
single set of libraries.
So it was easy.
But then the bad thing
is that the applications,
they don't have any isolation
whatsoever from each other.
So if you change something
in the operating system
or if you change something
in the libraries,
you could potentially break
any of these applications.
So it was easy to do, but
very easy to break as well.
Then we had virtual machines.
The idea with virtual
machines is that you
have a single physical machine.
But then you virtualize
the operating system
and the libraries
or your application.
So you put them in
a virtual machine.
The good thing here is that
applications are totally
separate from each other.
So they are totally isolated.
So if you change
something in one place,
it's not going effect
the other place.
But the bad thing is that
you have four operating
systems and four
set of libraries
that you need to worry about.
So this is a lot of
management overhead.
So what has happened
is that people use
virtual machines in production.
But they didn't really
use them as they
developed their applications.
Because it was a pain to
do, to manage all the stuff
from your laptop.
So it was more like a
deployment time kind
of thing, the virtual machines.
So with containers, you
have best of both worlds.
So in containers, you have
a single physical machine
and a single operating system.
But you are virtualizing
from libraries
up, so your application
and its dependencies.
You're virtualizing them in
what's called a container.
And these containers,
they are much smaller
than virtual machines.
So they're much
more lightweight.
So this way it's simple because
it's one machine, one operating
system.
But it's isolated as
well at the same time.
So it's combining the
best of both worlds.
So what is a container?
As I mentioned, it's
a lightweight way
of virtualizing
your applications.
They are sealed and isolated.
So you can have
multiple containers
on a single operating
system, and they don't
interfere with each other.
They are easy to deploy.
So compared to
virtual machines, you
can deploy stuff to a
container in seconds.
They're easier to introspect.
So you can actually SSH into
the container, look at what's
running, you can look at the
logs; all that kind of stuff.
And for me the most important
part is it's composable.
They are easy to compose.
So what you can have is
that there's a base image
that you depend on.
And then you can build your
image and your application
in a separate image that
depends on the base image.
And if people need to
depend on your application,
they can build an image
on top of your image.
So this way you can
layer your dependencies.
And this is very important.
Because that way if
someone depends on you,
all they have to do is get your
image and build on top of that.
So that's nice.
Oh, I should also mention,
Docker is the main container
platform that most people use.
But there are others,
like Rocket from CoreOS.
And I'm sure there will
be more going forward.
And also containers,
they might look
like there's something
new because we
started talking about them in
the last two or three years.
But at Google,
we've been running
containers for a long time,
for more than 12 years.
Everything in Google--
Gmail, search, even the virtual
machines within Google Cloud
perform; they run
within containers.
Because we like the
security element
of containers and our
whole infrastructure
is optimized for containers.
And actually we launched more
than 2 billion containers
per week.
So you can see the scale
of containers at Google.
So now let's take our
simple application,
and try to containerize it,
and see how that looks like.
So here I am in
Cloud Shell again.
I have my application.
First, what I need
to do is I need
to put all my application
and its dependencies
into a single DLL.
So this is a single
package for my application
basically that I'm
going to build.
To do that I run .NET
publish-c release.
So this will compile
my application.
It will compile all
of its dependencies,
and it will create a single DLL.
Later I'm going to use
this DLL from Docker.
So Docker will call this DLL.
So that's why I'm doing this.
So as this is a
building, next step
will be to build what's
called a Docker file.
A Docker file is basically
a blueprint for an image.
So it basically tells Docker
how to build your image.
So we'll create a Docker file.
And we'll take a look
at the Docker file.
Because it's very important
to see what's in there.
So we build our DLL.
And next we're going to copy
a Docker file that I created
into the release folder.
And we'll take a look at that.
So DLL is built. And let's
just go to the release folder
where my DLLs are.
I'll just double check
that everything is there.
Yes, I have my DLLs.
I only need the one that
I just built, actually.
So what I'm going
to do right now
is I'm copying the Docker file
that I already created to here.
And now we're going to
take a look at that file.
Because it's very important.
So let's just pause
here for a second.
So this Docker file, the
first line says from Microsoft
dotnet 101 runtime.
So this is the image
that I depend on.
So this is ASP .NET
Core application.
And it depends on an image
provided by Microsoft
called dotnet 101 runtime.
So this is the runtime
image that I depend on.
The second line says copy.app.
So it says copy everything
in this folder, the DLLs
to the app folder
in the container.
Then the third line says
the working directory app,
so the app folder
in the container
will be the working directory.
And then expose 8080.
So this will expose the
port 8080 in the container.
And the other one is an
environment variable.
So this is ASP .NET Core URLs.
So I am basically setting
an environment variable
to make sure that my
application starts on port 8080.
And the last line
is entry point.
So what happens when
the container starts?
So here I'm calling dotnet.
This is the command line tool
to run .NET applications.
And then I'm pointing to
the DLL that I just built.
So if you think about it, the
first line is my dependency.
The second through the
last line is my environment
that I'm setting.
And the last line
is what happens
when the container starts.
So with one file, I'm basically
defining my dependencies,
my environment, and what happens
when the container starts.
This is great, because
without this, you
have to basically tell people,
install this, install that, set
this environment this way.
So you have to give
all these instructions
and make sure that they
follow it properly.
But with Docker, you
don't have to do that.
You can just specify what
you want it to be true,
and it makes it happen.
So that's great.
So this is the Docker file.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to now build an image
from this Docker file.
So the image will basically
look at this Docker file.
And it will build an
image that we can use.
So to do that, we use
docker command line tool.
It's already installed
in Cloud Shell.
So you don't have to
install it yourself.
So I'm saying Docker
build-t means tag my image.
So I'm tagging it
with some data.
So gcr.io always refers for
Google Container Repository.
Because I'm going to push this
image through Google Cloud
Container Repository later.
And then Hello.net is
the name on my image,
and V1 is the
version on my image.
So it's based on looking
at the Docker file.
And it's going
through the steps.
The first step is my
dependency, what I depend on.
And it's an image
from Microsoft.
I don't have it.
So we are downloading
that from Docker Hub Base.
So it's getting the
image from Docker Hub,
and it will save it
to local Linux box.
So we're getting the image.
And then once we
have that image,
we'll go through
the other steps.
We'll copy files,
and we'll set up
our port, and all
that kind of stuff.
So we'll let that happen.
So the image is built. So if
we actually do Docker images,
we should see both our image
and our dependency image.
So if you do Docker images,
the first one is my image,
and the second one is the
image that I depend on.
So they're both on this machine.
Now I want to run this image
and make sure that it works.
So to do that I'll Docker run-d
it means run in the background.
And then -p means port, so I'm
mapping port 8080 on my machine
to port 8080 in the container.
And I'm just pointing to
my image that I just built.
So this basically runs
the image locally.
And once this is done,
I get a code hash code
that tells me it's running.
If I do Docker PS, I
see that it is running.
And then if I do web
preview, I should
see the same application.
But the difference in this
case is that this application
is running within Docker, within
the Docker Container basically.
So there you go.
The image is running.
So the next thing
that we're going to do
is once I have the
image, I'm going
to push that image
to Google Cloud.
So I'll do Docker stop
to stop my application.
And then I'll do a
GCloud Docker push.
So this way, I'm basically
taking the image that I just
built locally, and
I'm going to push it
to Google Container Repository.
So we'll fast forward this.
Because we don't
have that much time.
But then what you will
see is that basically
at the end of this, the
image will be pushed.
And we will be able to use
this image from Google Cloud.
So let's just get out of here.
So containers are
good, because now I
have an image that I
can push it to anywhere
and use it from anywhere.
So it gives me the
context I need.
But then to run
this in production,
there are still questions
that you need to answer.
For example, if you want
to have redundant services,
you need to run multiple
copies of these containers.
So you need to do that yourself.
If you want resiliency, you
need to create an endpoint.
If you want to
scale up and down,
you need to do that yourself.
So all this stuff that you
need to do in production,
you still need to do that.
Docker or containers, they
don't really help for that.
So that's when
Kubernetes comes in.
So Kubernetes,
it's a Greek word.
And it stands for governor.
Actually you're
right they of saying
Kubernetes is Kuvernetes.
But I guess it
started in the US,
and everyone calls it wrong.
But if you don't learn
anything in this talk,
just learn that it's
called Kuvernetes.
Basically it's a container
management platform.
It's 100% open source,
written and go.
It's supported by
companies like Google, IBM,
and many other big companies.
The greatest thing
about Kubernetes for me
is that it runs on
multiple cloud providers.
So you can have a
Kubernetes cluster that
runs on AWS, that can
run on Google Cloud,
and you can even have a
single Kubernetes cluster that
spans multiple cloud providers.
So that's the great
thing about it.
It came from
something called Borg,
which is an internal
container management
platform that we use at Google.
So people who worked
on Borg, they basically
learned from that
over the years.
And they created Kubernetes
for everyone else.
So at the high level,
this is how it looks like.
So you have a master that
has multiple things like API
servers and SCTs, and
schedulers and controllers.
And then you have nodes
where you actually
schedule containers.
They talk through
something called kubelets.
And then as a user,
you talk to the master,
either through APIs, CLI, or UI.
So at the high
level, if you want
to use Kubernetes
in Google Cloud,
you will basically build an
image through a Docker file.
You push that image to
Google Container Registry.
We just did that.
And then from there,
then on, first, you
need to create a
Kubernetes cluster.
So you use G Cloud to
create a Kubernetes cluster.
And then from then
on, you use kubectl,
which is the command line
tool to manage Kubernetes,
to schedule your images
to a Kubernetes cluster.
So now let's take a look at
how to create a Kubernetes
cluster in Google Cloud.
So first, as you
see, I push my image.
And if I go to Google Console
and go to Container Registry,
I should see my image
already in Google Cloud.
So I go here.
There's Hello.net.
And then there's
different versions.
But the version 1 is
the one that I pushed.
So now my image
lives in the cloud,
and I can use it in
many different places.
One of those is Kubernetes.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to use G Cloud again
to create the cluster.
So I'll say G Cloud
container clusters create.
And this will create a
Kubernetes cluster for me.
I'll give it a name.
So I'll call it
hello.net cluster.
And then I'm going to
specify how many nodes I
want to schedule my containers.
The number of nodes is 1.
And then machine
types is standard.
So there are different
machine types
in Google Cloud
that you can use.
But I'm using standard
machine types here.
And then I also
want to make sure
that this cluster
lives in Europe West.
So for zone I'm
saying Europe West.
So with this one line
of G Cloud command,
I will get a cluster,
with a master,
and with a single node, where
I can schedule containers.
And I can use that to
schedule my containers.
So if you go to
Container Engine,
I should see at some
point a cluster comes up.
So let's just fast-forward.
And at some point, I'll
see a cluster coming up.
And then from then on
I can use that cluster.
So it's just one
command basically.
In the last 10
minutes, I'm going
to cover what Kubernetes is.
So Kubernetes, it comes with
a lot of building blocks.
So this is some of them.
And there's even more.
We won't have time
to cover them all.
But feel free to stop
by, so I can tell
you tell you more about them.
But at the high level, this
is how a Kubernetes cluster
looks like.
You have your container.
From your container
you create what's
called a pod, which is
either a single container
or multiple
containers, depending
on what you want to do.
Then after that,
you create something
called replication controller.
So in a replication
controller, you basically
tell Kubernetes what
you want to be true.
Here I'm saying replicas, 3.
So I want three
copies of this pod.
Then Kubernetes
will look at that
and say, OK, I need
to create three pods.
It creates three pods,
and it schedules them
onto on some nodes.
But that's something
you don't have
to care about, like
Kubernetes figures out
where to schedule these nodes.
And then once these
pods are running,
you can expose them
to the outside world
using what's called a service.
So service is kind of like a
load balancer for your pods.
So, the first thing that I want
to talk about is deployment.
So in Kubernetes,
when you start you
create what's
called a deployment.
It's basically a high-level
construct that you create.
And under the covers it creates
all the lower-level things
that's needed to
run your containers.
So it creates pods.
It creates replica sets.
And it creates services for you.
And we'll look at what
those are shortly.
So let's just take a look at
how to create a deployment.
So here I am.
My cluster is ready.
And then I want to basically
schedule my first container
to Kubernetes.
First to do that, I
need to use kubectl.
But I need to authenticate this
shell with Kubernetes cluster.
So to do that, I
just run a command.
So once I run this
command, my shell
is authenticated
with Kubernetes.
And now I can use kubectl to
manage my Kubernetes cluster.
So I'll say kubectl run, and
I'll give my deployment a name.
So this is called hello.net.
And then I'll just
point to an image.
So I push this image from
my machine to Google Cloud.
So now since it's
in Google Cloud,
I can easily refer to
that and use the image.
And that's it.
So I just refer to my image.
And then I also
want to make sure
that the port 8080 is enabled.
So I'll say port 8080.
And then with this, we
basically created a deployment
in Kubernetes.
So it's just one command line.
So if you do kubectl
get deployment,
I should see that my
deployment is ready.
It's very fast.
And if I do kubectl
get pods, you
will see that I have
some pods being created.
So it's says status,
continue creating.
So it's creating the container
and it's trying to schedule it.
If I do get pods again, I
should see the status running.
So within a few
seconds, the container
is created and scheduled.
So that's great.
And then there's
also a replica set
that's been created
that we'll talk about.
And then there's also a
service that's been created.
And if you look at
the service, there's
an internal IP, cluster IP.
But there is no external IP.
Because I haven't exposed this
pod to the outside world yet.
We'll do that next.
So as you see, all the stuff
that I need is created.
So let's just briefly look at
what the rest of this stuff is.
So pods, volumes, and
labels; so I'll just
talk about them briefly.
So a pod is basically the
smallest scheduling unit
in Kubernetes.
Usually you have a single
container in a pod.
But sometimes there are
cases where you have
multiple containers in a pod.
For example, in this
case, I have a container
called file puller that pulls
some files from some content
manager.
And then it saves
it to a volume.
And then there's
another container
called Web Server that
serves from the volume
to the consumers.
So I want these two
containers and their storage--
that's called volume--
to live in a single unit.
So that's what a pod is.
A pod basically just
puts them all together.
And Kubernetes will
schedule that together,
and it will kill them
together, basically.
And a volume, as
I mentioned, it's
basic storage for the pods.
And you can attach a volume
to many different things,
like a persistent disk
or something like that.
So once you have your
pods, you can label them.
Labeling is the way you group
things together in Kubernetes.
So once you attach
labels to your pods,
you can use selectors
to get your pods.
So you can say, give
me all the pods,
all my application
using this way.
Or if you want to get all
your pods off the front end,
you can say this way,
and stuff like that.
So once you have
your pods, then you
can use something
called replica set.
Replicate set is the
favorite part of Kubernetes.
So you can think of replicate
set as a big brother watching
your pods.
So you tell replica set
what you want to be true,
and it makes sure
that what you want
is maintained at all times.
For example in this case, the
number of replicas is three.
And then there's some selectors
I'm using. op equals demo,
and color is blue or gray.
So I'm telling replica set,
make sure you have three pods
at all times with these labels.
And then it will maintain
those pods on some nodes
that I don't care about.
And if any of these nodes--
pods go down, it
will create a new pod
and schedule it on the nodes.
So it will make sure
that this is always true.
So I have a replica set.
Let me just show
you this quickly.
And this is probably
going to be the last demo.
So here I have my pods running.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to delete this pod
and see what happens.
So I'm going to
say kubectl delete,
and then passing the pod ID.
So what happens right
now is replica set
is watching on my pod.
So it will detect right away
that the pod is deleted,
and it will create a new one.
So if I do the delete, then
if I do get pods again,
you'll see a new pod with a new
ID has already been created.
It's says status,
continue creating.
So replica set, watches
basically your pod.
And as soon as it's
deleted or something,
it will create a new
one and schedule it
within seconds, which is good.
Because I don't have
to do that myself.
And then so you have your
pods, you have your labels,
and then you have your replica
sets watching your pods.
Now you're ready to expose
your pods to the outside world.
So you'll do that through
what's called services.
So the idea of service
is that you basically
use a selector to select the
pods that you want to expose.
In this case, I am
selecting all the parts
that have type equals FE.
So all the pods
that have that label
will be exposed
behind the service,
and the service will
have a stable virtual IP.
And the client will talk to
the service to get to the pods.
So to actually expose
our pod, it's again,
one line of code, command.
So I have my deployment running.
I have my pods running.
And if I want to
expose this pod,
all I have to say is
kubectl expose deployment,
pass in my deployment
ID, which is hello.net.
And then I will say type
equals load balancer.
So this will basically create a
load balancing in Google Cloud.
It will attach that to
our Kubernetes cluster.
And once the load
balancer has an IP,
we can hit that IP and it
will go through the service,
and it will get to the pod.
So here if I do
kubectl get service,
we'll see that the
external IP is pending.
Because it's creating a
load balancer right now.
And I will fast-forward because
we don't have that much time.
At some point when I
do kubectl get service,
I will have an external IP,
maybe on here, further down.
Yeah, now I have
the external IP.
So what this means is
that if I hit that IP,
I will hit the load
balancer, and that
will route me to the right pod.
So this is the
same code running,
but it's running within
a Docker container.
And it's being
managed by Kubernetes.
So Kubernetes watches
that container for us.
I only have two minutes.
So that means I
have to speak really
fast in the last two minutes.
But what I want to tell you
is so scaling in Kubernetes
becomes really easy.
So if you have three pods,
to scale to four pods,
all you have to do is just tell
replica set you want four pods,
and it would just
do it automatically,
with just one line
of code, very easy.
You can set auto scaling.
So you have your pods.
You can deploy something
called Heapster,
which is a real cool name,
that will collect all the CPU
metrics, if that's
what you want.
And it will report
to replicate set.
And replica set will
look at its rules.
And it will determine if the
CPU target is more than 50%,
create a new pod, and
it will just scale.
And I have a demo,
but I have to skip.
Then you can do
canary deployments.
So you can have
two replicate sets
with two different versions.
But you can expose them
behind the same service
and do canary deployments.
And then you can
the rolling updates.
So let's say you have a
version 1 of your application,
and you want to do an
update to the version 2,
you create a new replica
set in version 2,
and then add the
new pod to that.
And you expose everything
behind the same service.
And if everything looks
good, you take one out here,
you add one here, you take one
out there, you add one here,
you take one out there;
and if everything works,
you get rid of the replica set.
So to do this in Kubernetes,
it's again one command.
You just say update,
do a rolling update,
and it does all of this
for you automatically.
So I have a demo.
But I can't show that to you.
Because we don't have time.
But feel free to stop
by after the talk.
And then there's other stuff.
There's DaemonSets,
there are jobs,
there's config maps and secrets.
But we won't cover them here.
Just know that they exist.
So there's lots of
constructs basically
that makes your life easier
when you want to run containers
in production.
There's even more.
I didn't put it here.
But if you want to learn
more, kubernetes.io
is the page to go.
If you want to learn
about Container Engine,
cloud.google.com
/containerengine.
And if you want to get the
slides, follow me on Twitter.
And if you gave
any questions, I'm
going to be outside
the experts area.
Thanks a lot for listening.